Courtney has three kids she's never
looked better she's like the hottest mom
ever Kourtney Kardashian is one hot mama
who supports body positivity the 40 year
old Keeping Up with the Kardashians star
is getting major praise on social media
for posting this photo a super chic
swimsuit shot on a yacht but take a
closer look those are stretch marks and
Courtney is proud of them you just look
fab and you should own it embrace it and
left tons of sweet comments
complementing Kourtney's decision to not
edit out her stretch marks one user
wrote this is what a real body looks
like and another called the pic the
realest thing I've ever seen from you
guys
Kourt noticed all the kind comments and
even replied to one fan quote I love my
little stripes the body-positive photo
was posted to the Poosh account the
lifestyle brand Courtney founded earlier
this year not long after this memorable
moment on her fans reality show now that
Poosh is up and running
Courtney opened up to Glamour about
getting her business off the ground
explaining that she wanted to stay
focused on being a mom but the time felt
right to start something that felt
fulfilling quote I just wanted to have a
space where I could open up a
conversation where instead of being
judgmental or being like this is the way
and that's it
the site offers things to learn about
girl you keep doing you
[Music]
[Applause]